like a superhero but this weekend of the
movies he officially transforms into a
DC Comics superhero I sat down with him
to talk about becoming Black Adam
Heroes don't give
well I do I want to acknowledge you
you're always so kind to me like I saw
you last night and I haven't seen you in
person in four years like hey Chris good
to see you it's good to see you man so
if that's your superpower being kind
kindness well look man I always say like
kind being kind is and being nice uh and
I got I heard a quote when I was 15 and
I'll never forget it and I use it as my
lead foot by the way like in life which
is it's nice to be important but it's
more important to be nice so good and I
still feel that being nice and being
kind is
truly one of the easiest things to do
superpower what's your weakness
mine's Pizza mine's tequila
it's a bad combo there man that's a real
bad combo
you could destroyer of this
or you can be a savior with everything
that you've done in your career
wrestling Hollywood everything in
between you've had such an amazing
career how do you define success that's
a great question then you're making me
think about this I'm going to take a
crack at it right now I would say a
defined success by
having a positive influence on people
the number one anchoring element is to
always make sure that people walk away
feeling good and that's important walk
away feeling walk out of the theaters
feeling good watching a movie uh if
they're watching it at home they feel
good when the credits are rolling if
there's a product that I've created and
I deliver it they feel good with that
too as well so I define success by how
it makes people feel
they just catch a rocket
oh that was good Black Adam is in
theaters now well speaking of the rock
look at this